mes chers collègues je vous propose de
de commencer notre audition avec
monsieur le ministre de l'économie des
finances et de la souveraineté
industrielle et numérique un certain
nombre de nos collègues puisque nous
étions retenus dans l'hémicycle pour un
vote solennel sur le projet de loi
immigration vont nous rejoindre mais
pour autant monsieur le ministre pouvant
nous consacrer le temps jusqu'à 17h15 et
de toute façon nous avons à 17h30
l'audition avec le ministre de
l'Agriculture donc on va essayer de
perdre le moins de temps possible parce
que je sais que vous aurez les uns et
les autres énormément de questions à
poser à Monsieur le Ministre donc nous
avons le plaisir aujourd'hui de vous
entendre en votre qualité de ministre de
l'Économie des Finances de la
souveraineté industrielle et numérique
pour évoquer avec vous la stratégie de
politique économique de notre pays à
l'occasion du budget
2024 nos rapporteurs des différents
programmes vous poseront un certain
nombre de questions sur les budgets
qu'il rapporte je voudrais quant à moi
vous interroger sur la stratégie
économique que soutend ce budget
monsieur le ministre si vous me
permettez l'expression vous êtes le
ministre de tous les records record de
longévité à votre poste tout d'abord
plus de 6 ans une stabilité gage de
prévisibilité pour les acteurs
économiques mes collègues en
conviendront avec moi mais un autre
record dont vous seriez bien passé
celui-là c'est celui de la dette
publique avec un pic en 2020 l'année du
covid et encore en ratio de 110 % de
notre richesse nationale projeté en
2024 ces dépenses sont pour partie
l'héritage des crises sanitaires
géopolitique et énergétique que nous
venons de traverser et dans lesquels
nous sommes malheureusement encore
embarqué mais certains pensent ici que
c'est aussi le résultat de l'absence de
ciblage des aides décidées par votre
gouvernement à travers le quoi qu'il en
coûte et le bouclier tarifaire critiqué
par nombre d'économistes par le Fond
Monétaire International ou par le
Conseil d'analyse économique ma première
question s'agissant de ce budget est
donc la suivante comment mettre fin sans
dommages économiques à ces aides
grossièrement taillées pour mieux les
cibler et ainsi accélérer le rythme de
réduction des dépenses publiques toutes
les aides aux entreprises sont-elles
pour vous efficace ne faut-il pas les
réduire et si oui selon quels critère
voilà des questions que nous nous posons
à l'heure où le service de la dette
dépasse les 50 milliards d'euros à cause
de la remontée des taux d'intérêt c'est
maintenant le troisème poste de dépenses
de l'État derrière l' ignement et la
défense et ce sera d'ici la fin du
quinquena le premier poste de dépenses
ma crainte est que sans un effort sur ce
plan l'État ne soit pas bien armé pour
aborder les défis futurs à commencé par
celui de la transition écologique la
numérisation de notre économie et le
vieillissement démographique
incontestablement il existe des marges
de manœuvre pour faire mieux à moyen
constant grâce à une réallocation vers
les dépenses les plus productives à long
terme encore faut-il s'accorder sur sur
ce qui accroit la productivité à long
terme ou non et je constate que l'espace
public et médiatique est depuis quelques
temps déjà saturé d'objectifs politiques
annoncés d'en haut parfois directement
de la bouche du président de la
République sous forme de chiffres ronds
dont nous peinons parfois à trouver
l'évaluation économique sous-jacente
production de 1 million de pompes à
chaleur en
2027 de 1 million de voitures
électriques à la même échéance
plantation de 1 milliard d'arbres à
horizon
2030 et dans ce budget 10 milliards
d'euros de crédit supplémentaires sont
débloqués pour la planification
écologique avant même parfois d'avoir
précisément défini le détail de leur
affectation
ce qui revient me semble-t-il à prendre
les choses à l'envers ce retour du
volontarisme de l'État dans l'économie
tranche avec un passé pas si lointain et
forcément interroge la fixation
d'objectifs discrétionnaire fait-elle
désormais office de politique économique
je ne ni pas l'intérêt de la
planification pour organiser la
transition mais ne devrait-on pas faire
davantage confiance au marché et au prix
pour la transition on se retrouve dans
une situation un brin schizophrénique où
l'État anesthésie le signal prix du
marché en bloquant les prix de l'énergie
d'une main et donnant des stimulants de
l'autre via des subventions et de la
fiscalité verte pour inciter à la
décarbonation cette volonté de l'État de
tout organisé est-elle soutenable
comment séparez-vous ce qui relève du
marché et ce qui devrait relever de la
régulation économique s'agissant du
pouvoir d'achat vous avez amorti le choc
inflationniste dans un premier temps
avec succès puisque l'inflation avait
jusqu'à présent été mieux contenue ici
que chez nos grands voisins européens
mais en octobre 2023 selon Eurostat la
situation est inversée et la hausse des
prix est de 4,5 % en France contre 2 9 %
au sein de la zone euro l'état a-t-il
donc engagé des moyens importants qui
aurait eu pour s effet de décaler le
problème dans le temps nous venons de
discuter la semaine dernière de votre
projet de loi sur les négociations
commerciales en CMP et je dois dire que
l'examen de ce texte nous a laissé pour
le moins dubitatif sur l'ensemble des
rangs de cet hémicycle nous sommes le
seul pays d'Europe qui réglemente ces
négociations commerciales
avec le recul estimez-vous que le bilan
des différentes lois etgalim est positif
et comment justifiez-vous cette
singularité française avant de vous
céder la parole monsieur le ministre
j'aurais enfin une dernière question sur
un autre triste record celui de notre
déficit commercial on s'y serait presque
habitué s'il n'avait atteint en 2022 un
niveau inédit depuis entendez-vous bien
l'année 1949 9 2023 se traduit certes
par une réduction de ce déficit par
rapport à 2022 grâce à un dégonflement
des prix de l'énergie mais comment
Monsieur le Ministre expliquez-vous vous
qui communiquez volontiers sur
l'attractivité retrouvée de la France en
matière d'investissement que l'on puisse
voir les relocalisations et la
réindustrialisation partout dans la
communication du gouvernement sauf dans
les statistique de notre commerce
extérieur voilà monsieur le ministre je
vous cède la parole bien volontiers pour
répondre à ces quelques question et
ensuite nous commencerons bien sûr par
no nos collègues qui sont commissaires
et rapporteurs pour avis sur la mission
économique mais également par le
président de la Délégation aux
entreprises c'est à vous monsieur le
ministre merci beaucoup madame la
présidente mesdames messieurs les
sénateurs je voudrais d'abord vous
féliciter madame la Présidente pour pour
votre élection à la tête de cette
commission essentielle et vous me
permettrez de remercier votre
prédécesseur pour la qualité du travail
qui a été fait avec elle pour le
professionnalisme et la rigueur de ses
analyses qui ont souvent été sans
concession mais c'est comme ça que je
conçois l'efficacité du débat entre le
Parlement et le gouvernement donc je
consid que vous avez été une grande
présidente de la commission des affaires
économiques et je tenais à vous en
remercier je commencerai par répondre
aux questions qui m'ont été posées par
la nouvelle présidente avant de vous
donner mais les deux vont se rejoindre
les ligne de notre politique économique
et puis répondre évidemment à toutes les
questions que vous auriez à me poser
vous avez parlé madame la Présidente de
stabilité et de
prévisibilité je crois que rien n'est
plus précieux en matière de politique
économique et c'est pas simplement lié à
ma longévité dans mes fonctions c'est
surtout lié à la constance notre
politique économique nous avons mis en
place avec le président de la République
depuis 2017 une politique de l'offre et
nous maintiendrons une politique de
l'offre dans les années qui viennent
pour des résultats qui sont évidents et
donc pour une raison qui est très simple
c'est que la création d'emploi la
création d'entreprise et surtout ce qui
me tient le plus à cœur la
réindustrialisation du pays ont été
permises par cette politique de l'OF
nous ne varierons donc pas de la ligne
directrice qui a été fixée par le
Président de la République en 2017 fixé
à nouveau au moment de son élection en
2022 soutenir les entreprises soutenir
l'activité et permettre de développer
l'emploi sur notre territoire quels sont
nos objectifs il y a un objectif chiffré
le plein emploi 5 % de taux de chômage
et il y a un objectif plus politique
redevenir une grande nation de
production quand je regarde les années
et les décennies passées je pense que
l'erreur majeure qui été commise à la
fois par la France et par l'Union
européenne de manière générale mais plus
particulièrement par la France c'est
d'avoir abandonné sa production
industrielle ou agricole nous sommes la
nation développée qui a le plus
délocalisé ses activités économiques qui
a le plus abandonné ses ouvriers ses
usines ses compétences ses savoir-fa
avec à chaque fois des raisonnements
totalement fallacieux qui ont conduit la
France droit dans le mur nous nous
sommes engagés dans la voie de la
réindustrialisation notre objectif doit
être de redevenir une grande nation de
production industrielle et agricole et
c'est la première réponse que
j'apporterai à la question du déficit
commercial je pourrais m'abriter
derrière les prix de l'énergie la
facture de l'énergie ils expliquent en
grande partie l'explosion du déficit
commercial mais je pense qu'il est plus
intéressant de regarder la balance des
paiements et de s'apercevoir que si vous
rajoutez les services nous sommes
proches de l'équilibre alors que si vous
vous en tenez au biens manufacturiers
nous sommes effectivement déficitaires
c'est la preuve par A + B que la France
n'est plus depuis plusieurs décennies
une grande nation de production et qu'il
est indispensable comme nous l'avons
fait depuis 2017 de redevenir cette
grande nation de production que nous
avons été depuis plusieurs
siècles nous avons ensuite depuis 2017
eu à affronter deux crises historiques
la première c'est la crise du
covid je rappelle que c'est
l'effondrement du PNB le plus important
en France depuis
1929 ce pas une crise que vous effacez
comme cela d'un revers de la main cela
prend du temps j'estime que nous avons
fait face protégé avec efficacité et que
les dépenses qu' ét engagées pour
protéger les entreprises les industries
les commerces les restaurants les hôtels
étaent des dépenses justifiées et
nécessaires et d'ailleurs beaucoup
d'entre vous ici me réclamez parfois non
pas de faire moins mais de faire plus
pour ces entreprises si nous ne l'avions
pas fait nous n'aurions pas été la
première nation en Europe à retrouver le
niveau d'activité économique
d'avant-crise et surtout la France
serait un champ de ruine économique il
fais qu'un restaurateur qu'un
entrepreneur qu'un industriel a ferm
pour ouvrir boutique ça prend du temps
je pense que c'est un bon investissement
que de protéger dans ces circonstances
la deuxième crise historique c'est
l'inflation la crise inflationniste que
nous avons connu est la plus grave que
la France ait eu à subir depuis les
années
70 nous sortirons de cette crise
inflationniste en moins de 2 ans et nous
aurons eu en France un niveau
d'inflation cumulé le plus faible des
grandes économies de la zone euro
pourquoi tout simplement parce que nous
avons mis en place des boucliers
tarifaires sur l'énergie sur le gaz qui
nous ont évité des niveaux d'inflation
qui auraient été insupporta pour nos
compatriotes d'autres nations
européennes ont eu à connaître des
niveaux d'inflation de 15 16 20 25 %. ça
n'a pas été le cas en France et je pense
que c'est préférable de s'éviter des
niveau d'inflation aussi brutaux
l'inflation crée de la pauvreté c'est
inéductable l'inflation augmente les
inégalités c'est inéductable il y a pas
d'exception dans l'histoirec à ces
règles là l'inflation touche les plus
fragiles ce qu' les revenus les plus
modestes nous le savons tous et c'est
bien pour cela que nous avons pris ces
décision nous savions que l'inflation
allait pénaliser les plus faibles et les
plus modestes nous savions que
l'inflation pouvait augmenter le taux de
pauvreté dans notre pays et augmenté des
inégalités donc nous avons fait le choix
de mettre en place des protections qui
ont amorti le choc peut-être pas
suffisamment on peut toujours en
débattre mais nous avons fait ce choix
de protéger les plus modestes contre la
crise inflationniste avec le bouclier
tarifaire sur l'électricité et sur le
gaz maintenant nous rentrons dans une
période normale une période où
l'activité économique n'est plus menacée
par une inflation galopante nous sommes
en train de sortir de la crise
inflationniste et où il n'y a plus
d'effondrement de l'activité économique
comme pendant la crise du covid donc il
faut rétablir les finances publiques
lorsqu'on revient à la normale
il est indispensable de rétablir les
finances publiques autant il était
légitime pendant le covid pendant
l'inflation de protéger nos compatriotes
autant il serait
irresponsable de maintenir ces
dispositifs de précaution et de
protection au moment où nous revenons à
la normale encore plus irresponsable au
moment où les taux d'intérêt ont pris
plus de 200 points de base en l'espace
de quelques mois et où ils approchent
sur les dettes à 10 ans 3,5 3,6 % tout
ce que vous prenez comme engagement
financier supplémentaire tout ce que
vous levez comme dette supplémentaire à
un coût qui est infiniment plus
important avec ce niveau de taux
d'intérêt j'ai constaté ce matin que
même un grand économiste avec lequel
arrivé de débattre à plusieurs reprise
Olivier Blanchard qui estimait qu'on
pouvait s'endetter tenter plus est
revenu sur sa position et je salue la
nouvelle position qui a été prise par
Olivier Blanchard qui a évolué sur ce
sujet et qui a indiquéit qu'on pouvait
pas s'endetter tant et plus c'est
exactement ce que je défends depuis des
mois j'ai tiré la chette d'alarme il y a
un an en disant que la France était à
l'uro prês que nous avions atteint la
code d'alerte je ne cesse de demander
des économies supplémentaires et de
proposer des économies supplémentaires
et je tiendrai cette ligne là madame la
Présidente je veux vous rassurer de
retour à l'équilibre des finances
publiques ça n'est pas
négociable car ce serait
irresponsable de continuer à dépenser de
l'argent alors même que nous devons
rétablir les finances publiques et
investir dans des investissements
indispensables je pense à la sécurité la
guerre est de retour sur le sol européen
et évidemment la décarbonation notre
économie la transition climatique qui a
un coût très élevé si nous voulons
financer ces deux priorités il faut
savoir faire des économies ailleurs mais
on ne peut pas rajouter de la dépense à
la dépense ce serait suicidaire pour les
comptes publics français ce serait
suicidaire pour la nation française je
veux une nation forte et une nation
forte à des comptes publics bien
tenus enfin vous m'avez interrogé sur
deux sujet particulier qui sont
égalim j'ai répondu sur la question du
déficit commercial oui c'est une
singularité française égalim mais je
pense que c'est une bonne singularité
c'est une singularité qui vise à
protéger les revenus des producteurs et
qui dans le fond est le miroir de cette
hautre singularité française qui est
l'agriculture française avec des
produits de qualité des produits haut de
gamme des produits qui demandent du
temps du savoir-faire pour être réalisé
dans les meilleures conditions possibles
ça n'est que justice de protéger le
revenu des producteurs agricoles j'été 3
ans ministre de l'Agriculture je suis
favorable à tous les dispositifs qui
permettent de protéger le revenu de nos
agriculteurs alors certains disent il
faut toujours le prix le plus bas
possible mais c'est bien le cœur du
débat c'est un magnifique débat
politique est-ce qu'il faut le prix
toujours le plus bas possible quit estce
qu'il y a plus de producteur et qu'on
importe tout ça a été pendant longtemps
la politique de la France et de l'Europe
où est-ce qu'on admet qu'il peut y avoir
une protection du revenu du producteur
des prix qui soient plus élevés mais des
productions qui restent en France bien
moi je m'inscris résolument dans le
deuxème choix oui c'est plus cher de
produire des véhicules électriques en
France mais ils respecteront mieux les
normes européennes ils respecteront
mieux les règles environnementales et
ils seront produits avec du savoir-faire
français sur le territoire français avec
des ouvriers français et des ingénieurs
français sans avoir faire 6000 ou 7000
km avant d'arriver sur notre
sol tout cela un coût c'est le coût pour
rester une grande nation de
production je reviens sur notre
politique économique de manière plus
globale pour insister sur les résultats
que nous avons obtenus
des résultats en terme de croissance je
rappelle que notre croissance cumulée de
ces 6 dernières années est plus élevée
que celle de tous nos principaux
partenaires européens Allemagne Italie
Espagne Royaume-Uni cette solidité se
manifeste encore dans cette année 2023
on nous prédisait la récession j'ai
toujours indiqué que nous ferions 1 % de
croissance nous ferons 1 % de croissance
ça me donne un tout petit peu de
légitimité pour défendre 1,4 % de
croissance de l'année
suivante tout cela je le redit alors que
nous sortons de l'une des pires crises
inflationnistes de notre histoire
récente nous avons également obtenu des
résultats en terme d'attractivité pour
la 4e année consécutive la France est le
pays européen le plus attractif pour les
investissement étranger 13 milliards
d'euros d'investissement annoncé lors du
précédent sommet ch France au printemps
dernier attractivité qui concerne tous
les secteurs la finance la place de
Paris est devenue la nouvelle grande
place financière européenne honnêtement
ça n'était pas écrit il y a encore
quelques années la technologie avec 27
licornes en avance sur nos 25 licornes
qui était notre objectif pour 2025
l'industrie sur laquelle je reviendrai
enfin cette attractivité elle se traduit
en emploi 2 millions d'emplois depuis
2017 ont été créés et un taux de chômage
avec 7,2 % taux le plus bas depuis 40
ans avec cette croissance avec cette
attractivité nous avons obtenu des
résultats en terme de
réindustrialisation sold de net 300
ouvertures d'usine depuis 2017 alors
même que nous détruisions des usines
dans les décennies passées création donc
de 2 millions d'emplois dont 100000
emplois industriels et ouverture de
nouvelles filières comme celle des
batteries électriques avec l'ouverture
de 4 GIG Factory au total dans les
années qui viennent et de production de
semionducteurs maintenant
nous sommes au milieu
du il faut transformer l'essai
industriel et transformer l'ESS sur la
politique de
l'emploi j'ai eu l'occasion de le dire
on pourir un débat sur ce sujet le plein
emplo va pas tomber du ciel je crois pas
une
seconde pas arriver mécaniquement à 5%
de taux de chômage dans le fond un tout
petit peu provocquant débat politique
nous sommes déjà au plein emploi
en France à modèle social constant 7 %
c'est le plein emploi à modèle social
constant si nous voulons véritablement
parvenir à 5 % il faudra que notre
modèle évolue sur plusieurs points
d'abord il doit évoluer sur la formation
sur la qualification les décisions qui
ont été prises par le Président de la
République sur le lycée professionnel
sont indispensable pour orienter les
jeunes vers les filières dans lesquelles
on recrute pour plus avoir tous ces
emplois qui soi desemplois de couvreurs
ou de soudeur qui ne sont pas pourvu
tout simplement parce qu'on n pas
orienté les jeunes vers les emplois qui
étaient disponibles il faut qualifier
notamment qualifier les plus âgés et on
doit faire beaucoup mieux pour la
politique de qualification et formation
des personnes les plus âgées plus les
révolutions technologiques vont vite
plus il faut qualifier ceux qui ont 10
ans 20 ans ou 30 ans d'ancienneté de
leur entreprise c'est une priorité
absolue c'est ça le premier changement
du modèle social que j'appelle de mes
vœux et que nous commençons à mettre en
œuvre avec la réforme du lycée
professionnel
qualifier plus qualifier mieux former
davantage pour avoir une population
active qui corresponde au besoins des
entreprises et au révolutions
technologiqu en
cours deuxè changement notre modèle que
j'appelle de mes vux qui me paraît
nécessaire c'est la mobilité des
Français sujet extraordinairement
difficile qui suppose de s'attaquer à la
question du logement en particulier dans
les zones tendues je suis preneur de
toutes vos i sur le sujet mais je
constate simplement en me déplaçant
comme vous beaucoup dans le pays que
l'un des obstacles majeurs au
recrutement dans les zones qui sont déjà
quasiment au plein emploi c'est le
logement c'est le coût du logement c'est
l'accès au logement notamment pour les
jeunes qui démarrent dans la vie nous
devons avoir une politique du logement
qui favorise l'emploi enfin troisème
chose c'est notre politique
d'accompagnement d'indemnisation du
chômage nous devons regarder si les
règles actuelles d'indemnisation du
chômage nous permettent oui ou non de
parvenir au plein emploi voilà les trois
éléments sur le modèle social français
que nous devons interroger si nous avons
vraiment la volonté sincère au fond de
nous-même de passer de 7 à 5 % de taux
de chômage c'est-à-dire arrivver au
plein emploi en France ce qui n'est pas
arrivé depuis un demi-siècle donc si ça
n'est pas arrivé depuis un demi-siècle
ça veut dire qu'à model constant vous
n'y arriverez pas et c'est maintenant
qu'il faut prendre les décisions
nécessaires pour tenir l'objectif fixé
par le président de la République de 5 %
en 2027 c'est ma première priorité la
deuxième c'est la
réindustrialisation il est essentiel de
se saisir de l'opportunité de la
transition climatique et de la
décarbonation de l'économie pour
réindustrialiser le choix il est très
simple c'est à nouveau être une grande
nation de consommateur ou être une
grande nation de producteur on peut très
bien apporter tout l'hydrogène vert du
Maroc de des pays du Maghreb des pays du
golf où on peut vouloir produire de
l'hydrogène vert en France c'est pas la
même politique c'est pas les mêmes
investissements je souhaite évidemment
que nous produisions au moins une partie
de notre hydrogène vert en France avec
des électrolyseurs en France en nous
appuyant sur les grandes entreprises
comme Air Liquide ou sur les PME comme
live qui émergent aujourd'hui et qui
sont extraordinairement performante même
chose pour les véhicules électriques je
préfère qu'il soi produit sur le terr
français et que nous nous donnions les
moyens comme nous l'avons fait de les
produire en France qui suppose d'avoir
des batteries sur notre territoire 4 Go
Factory d'avoir des dispositifs de
recyclage des batteries en France nous y
travaillons de travailler sur la
production d'anode et de cathode sur le
territoire et d'avoir une politique
d'accès aux terres rares notamment au
lithium qui nous permet d'être
indépendant aussi sur les terres rares
qui je le rappelle sont en moyenne à 60
% aux mains des Chinois
aujourd'hui j'ajoute tout ce qui
concerne les semiconducteurs je
reviendrai sur la question de
l'intelligence artificielle mais cette
réindustrialisation verte doit nous
permettre d'être la première nation
décarbonée en Europe à horizon 2040 et
n'hésitons pas à dire que cette
politique de réindustrialisation elle
suppose aussi savoir nous défendre à
armes égales moi je suis évidemment
favorable un commerce qui soit équitable
et
réciproque mais je ne suis pas favorable
à un commerce mondial dans lequel tout
le monde respecte les règles à
l'exception de la Chine et des
États-Unis ou un commerce mondial vous
pouvez renverser les choses dans
lesquelles les pays européens sont les
seuls à respecter les règles d'un jeu
auquel les autres grands continent
n'adhère
plus une théorie des jeux qui dit que
celui qui perd systématiquement dans un
jeu c'est celui qui continue à respecter
des règles qui ne sont plus appliqué je
constate que Chine et États-Unis réserve
leurs aides budgétaires à des produits
industriels qui sont réalisés sur leur
sol moi il me semble qu'en prenant les
normes environnementales il est légitime
de réserver les aides à des productions
qui sont réalisées sur le sol européen
et que quand on donne des aides au
véhicules électriques des bonus qui je
le rappelle vont jusqu'à 7000 € par
véhicule c'est pas de la roupi de
sansonnet c'est 7000 € par véhicule bah
je préfère que c 7000 € à il y a des
véhicules qui sont produits dans des
conditions environnementales les plus
strictes de la planète ça tombe bien ce
sont les conditions
européennes trè priorité au-delà de la
réindustrialisation c'est celle de
l'innovation et de l'investissement dans
l'intelligence artificielle dans le
calcul quantique et dans les révolutions
qui sont en cours nous avons eu il y a
quelques jours un sommet très
intéressant à Londres autour du Pr
ministre Richi sunac sur l'intelligence
artificielle je vais vous dire ce que je
retiens de ce sommet dans le
fond nous sommes si nous n'y prenons pas
garde confrontés au risque de voir
demain l'Europe est à nouveau
consommateur de l'intelligence
artificielle générative américaine comme
elle a été depuis 40 ans consommateur du
digital américain dans les années 90
nous avons manqué la révolution digitale
nous avons laissé émerger les champions
mondiaux du digital que vous connaissez
bien et que vous utilisez tous les
Google les Amazon les Facebook et après
nous sommes arrivés après la cavalerie
en disant maintenant faut réguler tout
ça moi je soutiens cette régulation je
pense qu'elle est très bonne mais je
préfère que nous ne soyons pas
uniquement un continent de régulation
mais aussi un continent d'innovation et
je vais même pousser la réflexion plus
loin je pense que vous ne pouvez pas
réguler une innovation que vous ne
maîtrisez pas quand vous parlez
d'intelligence artificielle car vous
arrivz trop tard avec des machines des
algorithmes des super calculateurs qui
tourneront avec des données une culture
qui ne seront pas la vôtre donc j'estime
qu'il est indispensable notre politique
économique d'investir aussi massivement
à l'échelle nationale et européenne dans
l'intelligence artificielle pour pouvoir
demain disposer d'un chat GPT à
l'européenne et pas uniquement à
l'américaine ou à la
chinoise un tout dernier mot enfin pour
dire qu'une économie pour fonctionner a
besoin
d'énergie et que cette énergie c'est de
l'électricité décarboné au coût le plus
bas possible c'est un des atouts
compétitifs majeurs de la France c'est
la raison pour laquelle je pourrais
revenir si vous le souhaitez je me
félicite de l'accord que nous avons
trouvé après des mois de négociation un
an pour être tout à fait précis avec EDF
sur le prix de l'électricité pour
garantir à toute l'économie française
dans les décennies qui viennent un accès
sûr à une électricité décarbonée un coût
qui sera un des plus compétitifs en
Europe merci beaucoup monsieur le
ministre vous n'avez peut-être pas
répondu à ma question sur les aides les
aides aux entreprise sont-elles toutes
efficac ou en tout cas aujourd'hui
est-ce qu'il faut réfléchir à les
réduire ou à mieux les sélectionner mais
peut-être que le président de la
délégation au entreprise y reviendra
lorsque on posera la question si vous
voulez d'ors et déjà y répondre sur la
question de les aides aux
entreprises je je pense que les aides
aux entreprises comme toutes les aides
publiques méritent à chaque fois d'être
examiné attentivement par le Parlement
c'est son premier rôle et que nous en
tirions les conséquences je vous donne
un exemple très concret les allègement
de charge je suis évidemment favorable
aux allègements de charge qui
garantissent la compétitivité du coût du
travail français par rapport au grand
voisins européens mais nous devons avoir
l'assurance que ces allègements qui se
chiffrent en dizaines de milliards
d'euros donne les résultats attendus en
terme d'emploi et en terme d'embauche il
se trouve que deux parlementaires l'un
de la majorité l'autre de l'opposition
ont fait un rapport très précis sur les
allgements de charge entre 2,5 et 3,5
SMIC j'estime que ces allègements
restent nécessaires pour garantir la
compétitivité de l'industrie française
par rapport à l'industrie allemande
j'estime en revanche qu'avec l'inflation
l'indexation du SMIC à la fois sur le
niveau moyen des salaires et sur
l'inflation cela a généré des effets
distorsifs très importants pour les
entreprises dans les bas de grille dans
les bas de salair et par conséquent il
est légitime de geler le bandeau dit
famille entre 2,5 et 3,5 SMIC et que
maintenir exactement l'indexation sur
l'inflation de ce bandeau entre 2,5 et
3,5 SMIC serait une aide aux entreprises
disproportionnée par rapport aux
résultats attendus pass donc voilà un
exemple très concret sur lequel le
gouvernement a pris position nous sommes
favorables au gel du bandeau famille
entre 2,5 et 3,5 SMIC ça représente 800
millions d'euros de dépense c'est pas
rien et je pense qu'on gardera
exactement la même compétitivité par
rapport à nos partenaires notamment
allemands merci donc on va commencer par
nos rapporteurs pour avis de la mission
économie puis donc le président de la
Délégation aux entreprises donc on va
donner la parole à Sylvi Noë Anne
Catherine noisier Franck Montauger
Martine Berté et et Olivier Ritman soyez
s'il vous plaît assez concis parce que
sinon l'ensemble de nos collègues
n'auront pas le temps de poser toutes
les questions qu'il s'apprête à vous
poser Sylviane merci madame la
Présidente Monsieur le Ministre
l'artisanat d'art représente plus de 3
millions d'actifs en
France la stratégie nationale pour les
métiers d'art lancé fin mai
conjointement avec le ministère de
l'économie et de la culture est donc une
bonne nouvelle cela faisait des années
que l'artisanat ne faisait l'objet
aucune politique publique unifiée
cependant seulement 3 millions et demi
d'euros sont dédiés à la mise en œuvre
du volet économique de cette stratégie
op PLF 2024 et en dehors des métiers
d'art le soutien au secteur de
l'artisanat est quasiment inexistant
depuis 2019 et la disparition des FISAC
en parallèle les chambres de métiers
d'artisanat se voient amputé de 60
millions d'euros de recettes de taxes
pour frais de chambre d'ici 2027 dès
lors monsieur le ministre quelle
politique de en à l'artisanat
défendez-vous je profite également de ce
temps d'échange pour vous alerter
monsieur le ministre sur la question du
respect des délais de paiement
interentreprises comme vous le savez ce
respect est indispensable à la
compétitivité et à la viabilité des
entreprises particulièrement des PME or
au cours des auditions que j'ai mené la
DGCCRF m'a alerté sur une recrudescence
des retards de paiement de plus de 30
jours qui sont souvent le fait de
grandes entreprises ces pratiques sont
clairement exacerbées par l'inflation
pour vous donner un ordre d'idée au 1er
semestre 2023 la DGCCRF a lancé ou mené
à bien des procédures de sanction
administratives pour un total de 30
millions d'euros d'amende pour 224
entreprises malgré des capacités
financières conséquentes ces grandes
entreprises participent à d'importantes
rétention de trésorerie des PME qui du
fait les pénalisent la DGCCRF a par
exemple sanctionné Veolia à hauteur de
1,6 million d'euros nexan à hauteur de
850000 € ou encore McDo à hauteur de
200000 € ne serait-il pas temps de faire
évoluer les sanctions financières
encourues face à de telles pratiques
pour les rendre réellement dissuasives
je vous remercie Anne Catherine oisier
merci madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Ministre moi je résiste pas quand même
sur le sujet rapidement des galimes vous
avez réaffirmé votre volonté de protéger
les revenus des producteurs pourtant
dans la le dernière loi que nous avons
examiné sur les négociations
commerciales on renverse complètement la
logique puisqu'on donne la main au
distributeurs pour me mettent la
pression sur leurs fournisseurs ces
mêmes distributeurs qui par ailleurs
contournent la loi française en
développant des centrales d'achat à
l'étranger donc si vous pouvez nous
redire la cohérence de la la réflexion
par rapport à ça sera intéressant mon
sujet va au niveau des rapports budget
per va revenir sur le sujet du sur le
point du France très haut début et
notamment sur le volet du financement
des des raccordement complexe puisquen
fait nous le savons tous et nous nous en
félicitons le plan France dodébit se
déploie
relativement bien sur nos territoires
néanmoins il reste ce sujet majeur des
raccordements complexes à la fois sur le
domaine public et sur le domaine privé
une première enveloppe de 150 millions a
été débloquée sur 2 ans mais nous
constatons lors de ce budget qu'elle ne
sera pas renouvelée en 2024 alors que la
grande majorité de ces raccordements
complexes n'ont pas été pris en compte à
ce jour pour l'ensemble des
professionnels c'est le principal
obstacle aujourd'hui à la bonne
finalisation du plan Frost etodbi donc
comment expliquez-vous l'absence de
budget dédié au raccordement complexe
dans le le projet de budget 2024 et si
pour vous la reconduction d'une
enveloppe dédiée n'est pas la bonne
solution que proposez-vous par ailleurs
on nous parle d'un véhicule financier
qui pourrait être proposé aux
collectivités territoriales via la
Caisse des Dépôts donc qu'en est-il et
puis pour finir une rapidement une une
question sur le financement des
conseillers numériques dans les maisons
service qui inquiète et qui préoccupe de
plus en plus nos collègues élus locaux
puisqu'il y avait un abondement et un
soutien massif les premières années qui
semble aujourdhui diminuer de manière
importante et qui remet en cause la
pérennité de ses postes merci Fran
monuger merci madame la Présidente merci
Monsieur le le ministre vous vous l'avez
évoqué très très rapidement est-ce que
vous pourriez nous nous
présenter les éléments princip ip de
l'accord qui est intervenu avec
EDF sur les prix et la
structuration du du marché poste post
Aren et qu'est-ce qui va en résulter
pour les consommateurs et les
entreprises en particulier bon le le
poste àen c'est
2026 pendant les de années à venir
qu'est-ce qu'on fait est-ce qu'on reste
dans un statut co avec les difficultés
que l'on sait pour les particuliers les
entreprises et les collectivités locales
je vous pose la question
euh concernant euh vous vous vous
félicitez de de de de l'implantation de
de de giga Factory c'est effectivement
de l'emploi de l'emploi en plus euh mais
euh on a eu le débat lors de la
discussion de la loi industrie verte
qu'est-ce que vous faites de de de de
spécifique pour les les investissement
des des ETI des PME et autres TPE sur
tous les territoires euh euh qui
contribue en fait à à la chaîne à la
chaîne de valeur de valeur
globale question
complémentaire nous nous partons nous
parlons beaucoup de transition
écologique de renforcement de de
l'attractivité économique de nos de nos
de nos
territoires je voudrais
savoir quel est votre politique
exactement par par rapport au crédit
d'impôt vert comment euh vous le
mobilisez est-ce que vous le
conditionnez euh à des actions
particulières de la part des entreprises
eu qui pourrait qui pourrait en
bénéficier quelle est votre politique à
à à à à cet à cet égard voilà euh je je
termine juste sur un point par une
réaction euh vous avez évoqué chat JPT
moi avec d'autres hélas j'ai
l'impression que c'est mort ce sujet et
qu'on va une fois de plus courir en gros
après les Américains voilà euh euh
j'ai l'impression qu'on a pas tiré les
les les leçons de l'épisode précédent
concernant relatif à la à la à la
numérisation et la numérisation des des
des marchés en particulier c'est assez
c'est assez regrettable et c'est surtout
dommageable pour pour l'économie
française et européenne merci Franck
Martine Berté
oui merci madame la présidente monsieur
le ministre vous n disiez que
l'industrie enfin le soutien à
l'industrie est une de vous
priorités alors de deux questions par
rapport à ce soutien vous parliez des
allègements gelés au niveau de 2023 pour
les charge sociale des entreprises
l'UIMM évalue à un coût de plus de 140
millions d'euros C allègement par an
voilà donc est-ce que cela ne vient pas
contredire ce soutien et sur le deuxème
point l'accord avec le DF entre DF
pardon et le gouvernement pour un coût
de l'électricité à 70 € il me semble
c'est très bien mais les industriels
électro et hyper électrointensifs ont
besoin d'un coupt moindre pour rester
compétitif avec la Chine et les
États-Unis vous en parliez également
tout à l'heure donc est-ce que ce coût
peut être vu à la baisse notamment dans
le cadre des contrats long terme le le
coût est évalué par la creux à 60 € et
qu'en sera-t-il de toute façon pour 2024
et 2025 je vous remercie merci et pour
terminer que le ministre ne réponde le
président de délégation aux entreprises
Olivier
RMAN merci madame la Présidente Monsieur
le Ministre une fois encore ce projet de
loi de finance qui promet une réduction
de la dépense publique est un beau
trompeleuil à rebours de vos promesses
il prévoit notamment de nouveaux
prélèvements sur les entreprises quelle
surprise la liste est longue mais je ne
citerai que deux exemples l'augmentation
du versement mobilité des entreprises
franiliennes de près de 400 millions
d'euros le décal dans le temps de la
réforme des impôts de production qui
était une réforme pourtant indispensable
à notre compétitivité et qui avait enfin
été actée après des années de
tergiversation avec les différentes
mesures du PLF et du PLFSS et les
récentes décisions de la Cour de
cassation le coût du travail en France
pourrait être renchéri de près de 4
milliards d'euros dès l'année prochaine
les organisations patronnales ont
d'ailleurs tirer la sonnette d'alarme
jeudi dernier devant la délégation aux
entreprises que je préside nous
apprenons en outre que votre
gouvernement prépare pour ce PLF 2024
une réforme du pacte du truille au-delà
d'une simple mesure antiffraude dévoilée
par voie d'amendement à l'Assemblée
nationale il s'agirait en réalité
d'aller beaucoup plus loin de
n'appliquer l'allègement fiscal qu'à
seulement 15 % de la trésorerie d'une
entreprise charge à l'administration
fiscale de décider du sort du reste très
rassurant pour nos entreprises comment
pouvez-vous imaginer séparer ainsi le
patrimoine de l'entreprise de sa tr
et transmett l'un des dans des
conditions différentes de l'autre c'est
un nonsens total et une boîte de Pandor
pour le contentieux juridique le pacte
du treuille est pourtant un outil
indispensable pour assurer la
transmission de nos PME et ETI familial
la moitié d'entre ell devra être
transmise dans les 10 ans à venir
l'enjeu n'est plus n'est ni plus ni
moins que la survie de notre tissu
économique à ce changement générationnel
ma question monsieur le ministre
pouvez-vous dire clairement si vous avez
effectivement l'intention de mener une
telle réforme qui passerait par
amendement et donc ne comporterait
aucune étude d'impact sérieuse préalable
si tel est le cas je vous demanderai
d'associer à vos travaux au plus vite le
Sénat qui a travailler sur ce dispositif
et qui formule des propositions
autrement plus urgentes et pertinentes
que Cell qui figurent dans cet
amendement je vous remercie merci
Olivier voilà Monsieur ministre je
propose de répondre à l'ensemble de ces
questions
déjà merci madame la Présidente je vais
commencer par la dernière question celle
d'Olivier Ritman pour le rassurer tout
de suite il n'est pas du tout dans les
intentions du gouvernement de faire une
nouvelle réforme du pacte du trille que
les choses soient bien claires j'ai
porté c'est le mérite de la constance et
de la durée qui a eu la gentillesse de
rappeler Dominique
estrosissasson j'ai eu l'occasion de
présenter une réforme en profondeur du
pacte du tril en 2018 ce n'est pas pour
la détricoter 5 ans plus tard qu'il y
ait des abus ici ou là parfaitement
documenté oui qu'il faille contrôler ses
abus oui qu'il faille ensuite engager
une nouvelle réforme en profondeur du
pacte du tril non pacte du tril permet
de garantir la transmission des
entreprises familiales je suis attaché
au capitalisme familial donc il n'est
pas question d'engager une nouvelle
réforme en profondeur du pacte du trille
je partage aussi votre préoccupation sur
la décision de la Cour de cassation elle
s'impose à tous mais je partage votre
préoccupation sur les risques cela fait
peser sur le coût du travail enfin je
vais vous répondre avec la même
franchise sur les deux autres questions
sur la CVE je rappelle que 1 milliard
d'euros c'est la baisse d'impôt la plus
importante de ce PLF 2024 nous sommes
dans des temps budgétaires difficiles et
ma responsabilité est de prendre des
décisions difficiles y compris avec les
entreprises donc je revendique cette
décision je l'ai déjà expliqué à
plusieurs reprises aux industriels
concernés
je ne peux pas faire 4 milliards d'euros
de baisse d'impôt d'un coup dans la
situation budgétaire où nous sommes ce
sera à la fois irresponsable et injuste
donc nous allons étaler cette baisse de
CVAE sur 4 ans si nous pouvons le faire
plus rapidement parce que la conjoncture
est meilleure nous le ferons je reste à
fervant défenseur de la suppression de
ces impôts de production qui pèsent trop
lourdement sur notre industrie mais je
le fait au rythme que mutorise nos
comptes publics quant au versement
mobilité chacun sait quelle est ma
position et chacun c'est ce que je pense
de l'accord qui a été conclu entre la
Présidente de la Région île-de-fance et
le Gouvernement sur ce sujet je ne suis
pas favorable à ce qu'on augmente par un
biais ou par un autre les impôts de
production dans notre pays ces 400
millions d'euros c'est beaucoup et si
nous voulons rouvrir de la production
des usines dans notre pays il faut
éviter les solutions qui font peser sur
la production française des charges
fiscales trop
lourdes syvien Noël sur l'artisan d'Ar
je rappelle juste qu'il bénéficie des
allègements et des aides dont
bénéficient toutes les autres
entreprises et que par ailleurs nous
travaillons bien avec les CMA je vous
rejoins totalement sur la question des
délais de paiement inter
entreprise il est
indispensable d'avoir de la part des
entreprise je dirais aussi de la part
des pouvoirs publics qui sont pas
toujours les meilleurs payeurs des de
paiement qui soit beaucoup plus réduit
j'ai demandé à la DGCCRF de porter une
attention particulière à ce sujet si les
parlementaires estime qu'il faut
renforcer les sanctions en matière de dé
paiement je suis tout à fait ouvert à
cette
discussion Anne-Catherine Loisier sur
les raccordements complexes le travail
est en cours et je vous confirme que
nous déploierons les moyens nécessairire
pour stabiliser le nombre des
conseillers numériques j'ai entendu
effectivement les inquiétudes qui
remontaient des territoires sur ce sujet
c'est jeannoël Barot qui est chargé de
mettre cela en œuvre Fran montoger sur
l'accord
EDF un mot là-dessus que c'est un enjeu
évidemment
majeur dans le fond il y avait deux
façons d'aborder cette négociation sur
les tarifs deélectricité quel est
l'enjeu l'enjeu c'est partir de 2026ah
il y a plus d'arène donc il n'y a plus
de tarif régulés donc première option on
va dire qu'il y en avait
troère option c'est de dire il y a plus
de régulation du tout et c'est
uniquement le marché mais comme ça n'a
même pas été une option de départ pour
le gouvernement je la considère pas
comme une véritable option une option de
papier deuxème option c'est de dire
EDF a été nationalisé c'est une
entreprise publique donc il faut que les
prix soient cassés peu importe la
rentabilité de DF et elle peut très bien
produire de l'électricité à
perte je me suis suis opposé à cette
idée là qui a beaucoup circulé
elle est à 100 % publique
est à 100 % à capitaux public terme de
nationalisé vous avez raison n'est pas
tout à fait approprié je le dis par
souci de simplification elle est à 100 %
à capitaux public ça change pas
grand-chose au résultat final certains
estimaient que à partir du moment où les
capitaux étaient 100 % publics il
fallait que l'État décide chaque année
un prix le plus attractif possible
quitte à ce que l'entreprise vende à
perte moi je suis désolé je ne
sacrifierai pas
EDF je ne je vais y venir je ne
sacrifierai pas EDF et je n'ai pas voulu
prendre de décision qui auraiit
sacrifier EDF et les dizaines de
milliers de salariés deedf une
entreprise qu'elle soit à capitaux
public ou à capitaux privé ne vend pas à
perte sinon elle fait faillite et quand
elle a 65 milliards d'euros de dett
c'està-dire que chaque année elle doit
aller lever de la dette sur les marchés
avec des taux d'intérêt plus élevés il
aurait été irresponsable je dis bien
irresponsable de demander à EDF de
vendre à
perte donc nous avons voulu c'était la
troisème option trouver un équilibre
entre la rentabilité indispensable de DF
la compétitivité pour les entreprises et
la stabilité pour les ménages c'est très
sincèrement je pense ce que nous avons
trouvé avec Luc Crémont le président
directeur général de DF après aès un an
de négociation comment est-ce que cela
va fonctionner d'abord première
différence avec le système précédent la
régulation du tarif deélectricité va
porter sur 100 % de la production
électrique de DF c'est l'immense
différence par rapport au système
précédent et ces fameux 42 € mgaw que
tout le monde sort matin midi et soir en
oubliant de rappeler un petit détail
c'est que ça ne porte que sur un/3 de la
production de DF sans terwh
110 alors que EDF produit entre 300 350
tawh avec un objectif à terme de 450
tawh donc le reste et nous avons
expliqué des choses très clairement aux
entreprises était exposé au marché donc
le choix était entre avoir une
régulation avec un prix de référence à
70 € le MWh c'est ce que nous avons
retenu sur 100 % de la production
électrique nucléaire de DF
ou avoir un prix de référence beaucoup
plus bas mais ne portant que sur un/ers
de la production électrique nucléaire de
DF tout le reste étant exposé au marché
et comme j'ai l'habitude de dire les
choses clairement j'ai dit aussi très
clairement que dans la situation
actuelle des finances public si les prix
flambai et prenaient 100 % ce qui peut
arriver si demain vous avez une
extension du conflit au proch Orient
l'État ne serait pas là car je n'ai plus
les moyens de compenser c'est une
explosion des prix de l'électricité sur
le marché donc vous avez le choix entre
la sécurité ou le risque nous avons fait
le choix de la sécurité et de la
stabilité pour les entreprises comme
pour les ménages 100 % de prix autour de
70 € le mgawh ça reste trop cher pour un
certain nombre d'entreprises
énergosensibles elles sont 6600
représentant 40wh à charge pour ODF
suivant des modalités que nous avons
étudié qui seront mis en œuvre dans les
6 mois qui viennent de trouver des
solutions sous 6 mois pour ces
entreprises
énergointensives pour les entreprises
électrointensiv et hyper
électrointensive des solutions on ét
trouvé sous la forme de contrats de très
long terme les fameux CAPN sur 15 ans
parce que ces entreprises ont les reins
suffisamment solides pour faire une
avance en tête c'est-à-dire qu'elles
prennent en fait une partie du capital
de DF et la production d'électricité
nucléaire de DF ce qui leur permet avoir
un tarif encore plus compétitif et
certainement sont donné de chiffres un
des tarifs les plus compétitifs de tous
les pays européens pour les
consommateurs cel leur donne de la
stabilité sur les prix et l'assurance
qu' ne seront pas confrontés à une
explosion des prix comme celle que nous
avons connu car je rappelle que si nous
n'avions pas mis en place le bouclier
tarifire sur l'électricité une facture
de 1500 € par an qui est à peu près la
facture moyenne pour un ménage moyen en
France serait passé à 3000 €. à 3000 €
nous avons mis en place un bouclier
tarifaire 40 milliards d'euros je peux
le faire une fois je peux pas le faire
deux fois donc il était indispensable de
donner de la stabilité et de la
visibilité au consommateurs c'est ce qui
a été fait enfin je rappelle que nous
maintenons des tarif régulés pour les
ménages au-delà de
2026 que nous le maintenons aussi pour
les TPE et grand changement majeur que
vous avez tous réclamé ici même chose à
l'Assemblée nationale désormais ces
tarifes régulés ne seront pas limité par
le niveau de consommation des très
petites entreprises à 36 kV ampè mais
seront ouverts à toutes les très petites
entreprises quel que soit leur niveau de
consommation électrique il suffit d'être
une très petite entreprise c'est-à-dire
moins de 10 salariés moins de 2 million
d'euros de chiffre d'affaires voilà
l'accord auquel nous sommes parvenus je
pense que c'est un accord équilibré qui
préserve les intérêts de DF la
compétitivité des entreprises et la
stabilité des prix pour les
ménages pendant les 2 ans nous restons
au système actuel et nous avons pour
être tout à fait précis un rendez-vous
dans 6 mois pour nous assurer que cet
accord se traduit par des contrats pour
les entreprises dans les meilleures
conditions possibles et par ailleurs la
mise en uvre de cet accord fera l'objet
d'une clause de revoyure tous les 3 ans
pour nous assurer que les prix retenu
correspondent aussi à la réalité du
marché sur euh le crédit d'impôt vert je
rappelle juste qu'il s'applique très
précisément à quatre types de production
les pompes à chaleur les panneaux
solaires les éléments d'éolienne et les
batteries électriques donc nous avons
fait le choix de restreindre un certain
nombre d'activités par souci de ménager
les finances publiques le crédit d'impôt
n'est pas ouvert à l'hydrogène vert pour
des raisons très simples de coût
budgétaire enfin sur Chat
GPT je sais que le défi est énorme je
pense qu'il ne faut pas baisser les bras
je pense que nous avons des atouts sur
les super calculateurs avec Jan che
super calculateur de nouvelle génération
que nous travaillons avec les Allemands
et les Espagnols nous avons des startup
très dynamique et brillante comme
Mistral dirigé par Arthur mench nous
avons en matière de données des données
qui font référence notamment dans le
domaine de la santé qui peuvent être
très précieuses pour la mise en place de
cette intelligence artificielle
générative donc je reconnais bien
volontiers comme vous que le défi est
considérable je pense qu'il ne faut pas
abandonner l'objectif d'avoir une
intelligence artificielle générative
européenne dans les années qui viennent
estce que ce sera possible je ne le dis
pas à s chance contre 100 est-ce que
nous aurons tous les éléments ça n'est
pas certain prenez par exemple les GPU
les unités de processeur graphique
aujourd'hui à 92 % il sont produits par
l'entreprise américaine Nvidia je suis
pas sûr que nous ayons les moyens de
faire concurrence à Nvidia donc il y a
sans doute des éléments et des blocs sur
lesquels nous serons dépendants mais
nous ne devons pas renoncer à cet
objectif d'avoir une intelligence
artificielle générative qui soit
européenne enfin je pense Martine sur
les 70 € pour les énergos sensibles
c'est une question effectivement majeure
dans le fond les électrro intensifs et
hip électrointensif sont traités par les
contrats d'allocation de production
nucléaire de très long terme 15 ans mais
eux peuvent se permettre je le disais de
faire des avances en tête l'immense
majorité des entreprises industrielles
n'ont pas de sensibilité suffisante au
prix d'électricité pour que l'accord qui
a été conclu leur pose difficultés reste
les 6600 entreprises énergosensibles sur
lesquelles nous travaillons avec EDF à
des options pour être en dessous de ces
70 € qui sont trop élevés pour
merci donc on va passer à des questions
3 par 3 je vous demande vraiment d'être
concis sinon on a une demi-heure encore
avec Monsieur le Ministre et donc vous
arriverez pas tous à poser votre
question on va entendre Frédéric Buval
Fabien Guay et Patrick chaise très
rapidement s'il vous plaît oui merci
madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Ministre comme vous le savez le Conseil
interministériel leum du 18 juillet
dernier a prévu une réforme de l' de
maire dans un objectif de baisse des
prix des produits de grandne
consommation dont les modalités sont
inscrites au plus tard dans le projet de
loi de finan
2025 si je souhaite vous alerter dès
maintenant c'est parce que les acteurs
économiques et les élus locaux des
départements d'outremè sont inquiets et
souhaitent être eux aussi associés à
cette réforme deroit de ma qui sera très
importante pour l'avenir de nots
territoire en effet cette réforme aura
un impact direct sur l'activité des
entreprises commer en terme d'emploi et
de croissance et plus particulièrement
sur l'activité de celles qui font de la
production locale et qui sont déjà
confrontés à des difficultés de
concurrence avec les produits importés
en outre le de ma représente également
une ressource capital pour les
collectivités locales qui finanent
notamment des services publics
essentiels et qui financent la commande
publique la réforme de trit de mer
monsieur le ministre pour qu'elle soit
réussie et équitable doit être conçu de
manière à compenser les pertes de
recettes pour les entreprises locales
des collectivités territoriales tout en
améliorant le pouvoir d'achat des
consommateurs ma question est simple
monsieur le ministre pouvez-vous
m'indiquer comment seront associés sur
chaque territoire les acteurs
économiques et des collectivités locales
pour que cette réforme d'importance soit
réussie en notre mare merci merci Fabien
Guay merci Madame la président bonjour
monsieur le ministre très heureux de
vous revoir très heureux de vous revoir
vous VO je le dis pas
assez bon je reviens pas sur le tout ça
je suis obligé d'aller à la Serbe j'ai
40 secondes donc
1 moi j'entends quoi qu'il arrive vous
traversez toutes les crises monsieur le
ministre vous restez droit dans vos
votes et sûr de vos convictions il y a
rien qui peut vous ébranler vous
continuez sur la politique de
l'offreon 13 million de pr
compris 6 million les aides alimentaires
qui explosent tout ça bon et les
précaires énergétique et on a une
question qui est centrale c'est la
question du salaire on vous vous ne
répondez que par à coup par chèque ou
par intéressement investissement tout ça
actionnariat salarié vous êtes déclaré
favorable à l'augmentation des petits
salaires moi je voulais savoir bon vous
posez beaucoup de fois la question vous
faites beaucoup de petits déjeuner avec
le patronat pour exiger la
l'augmentation des salaires mais ça ne
marche pas est-ce qu'il faut pas passer
par la loi à un moment donné une
augmentation significative du SMIC qui
déclencherait une conférence sociale
partout en France et en 10 secondes
Atos quand même dont on parle beaucoup
un spécialiste du numérique décarbonés
euh là on peut pas dire que c'est euh
c'est un fluron industriel mais on peut
pas dire que les dernières semaines les
derniers mois voir les dernières années
c'est la question industrielle qui a
prédominé là on pourrait dire c'est
c'est là pas du gain vous voyez pourquoi
rester opposé
à une potentielle renationalisation
temporaire pour sauver Athos parce que
là c'est un de nos gros floron voilà je
vous
remercie Patrick cheaz merci madame la
Présidente Monsieur le Ministre trois
questions rapides tout d'abord la
question du déploiement du très haut
débit à Mayotte mayott est le dernier
département français à ne pas disposer
d'un projet financé euh alors que les
élus ont enfin déposé leur dossier il
est collectivement annui qu'un
financement dans le cadre du FSN doit
leur être réservé or le projet de loi de
finan 2024 occulte ce projet donc je
vous voudrais savoir s'il serait pas
opportun qu'au moins une autorisation
d'engagement soit inscrit pour rassurer
les élus et permettre le démarrage de
l'opération deuxème sujet La Poste La
Poste assure quatre missions de service
public et qui doit faire l'objet de
compensation financière le service
universel postal est souscompensé de 20
millions d'euros mais je voudrais
surtout attirer votre attention sur la
mission aménagement du territoire qui si
l'on se réfère à l'objectif du contrat
de présence postale est souscompensé
dans le dans la maquette de 15 million
d'euros si on se réfère à l'estimation
et si on se réfère à l'estimation de
l'arcepp c'est plus de 190 millions
d'euros qu'il manquerait ceci est
d'autant plus inquiétant que le montant
alimente un fond adossé au contrat de
présence postale qui est directement
injecté dans les territoires par
l'intermédiaire des commissions
départementales de présence postale
territoriale et enfin 3e sujet l'arcepep
le projet de loi visant à sécuriser et à
réguler l'espace numérique toujours en
cours de discussion parlementaire trouve
déjà ses premières applications
budgétaires dans le cadre de ce nouveau
projet de loi de finances les
différentes autorités nationales de
régulation chargées de faire respecter
les règlements européens sur les
services et les marchés numériques
bénéficieront dès 2024 d'une hausse de
leur budget budget de fonctionnement ou
de leur effectif afin de faire face à
leurs nouvelles obligations en
particulier l'arcom l'acnil et
l'Autorité de la concurrence alors que
d'importantes et nouvelles attributions
sont confiées à l'ARSEP en matière de
régulation des opérateurs d'informatique
en nuage et d'intermédiation des données
de marchés à fort potentiel de
croissance et dont le bon développement
est indispensable à l'attente de la
souveraineté numérique de notre pays
aucune hausse supplémentaire ni de
moyens ni d'effectifs n'est
envisagé cette absence est d'autant plus
préjudiciable que l'ARCEP devra saisir
de ces nouvelles attributions dès 2024
alors qu'elle ne dispose pas de compéten
internes pour le faire or pour devenir
gendarme des données lorsqu'on est
gendarme de la fibre le chemin est long
et vous savez comme moi qu'un gendarme
disposant simplement de son uniforme
pour faire son travail sans avoir les
moyens de faire respecter la loi n'ira
pas bien loin alors Monsieur le Ministre
comment expliquez-vous cette situation
êtes-vous favorable à une correction de
cet oubli dans le cadre de l'examen au
Sénat de ce projet de loi de finance je
vous remercie merci monsieur le ministre
je vous propose de répondre à ces
questions de trois commissaires parce
qu'il y en a pas que trois de questions
je vais commencer par la dernière
question de de Patrick chaise moi je je
vais vous dire je ne suis pas favorable
à des augmentations de dépenses que ce
soit pour l'ARSEP ou pour qui que ce
soit donc je veux bien que les autorités
indépendantes demande plus de moyens
mais à un moment donné il y a de fils
qui se touchent on nous dit notamment
sur ces ban de l'Assemblée je vous en
remercie que il faut des comptes mieux
tenus qu'il faut réduire les dépenses
qu'il faut réduire la je suis
entièrement d'accord faites-moi des
propositions d'économie
y je les reprendrai
faites-les-mi faitesles- moi mais je ne
peux pas envisager d'augmentation
systématique des moyens des autorités
indépendantes parce que ce serait
contradictoire avec mes objectifs de
réduction de la dette et des déficits
sur le TR au débit à Mayot je verrai le
président de bayot la semaine prochaine
donc là nous avons un sujet d'équité
majeur donc évidemment la question sera
traitée fréric Berval très rapidement
que les choses soient bien claires je ne
ferai pas de réforme de droit de mer
sans les élus locaux et sans les
entreprises locales ça n'a absolument
aucun sens les élus locaux vivent de cet
Ox Frid de mer il y a pas de
compensation possible pour des montants
aussi importants qui s'élèvent de
mémoire à 230 millions d'euros donc il
est impératif de faire cette réforme
avec les euus locaux et avec les acteurs
économiques locaux avec pour objectif
d'introduire les premières dispositions
dans le PLF
2025 Fabien Guay d'abord c'est un
plaisir de vous
revoir plaisir partager
ensuite c'est trop rare je vous rassurai
tout de suite je je suis pas quelqu'un
de droit dans ses bottes je suis
quelqu'un de Constant je me méfie des
gens droit dans leur botes parfois il
faut
savoir parfois tout le temps écouter
corriger ce qui peut être corrigé jeai
de cesse de le faire faire tout en
restant fidèle à la ligne de politique
économique qui est celle du gouvernement
mais bien entendu que l'inflation a un
impact extrêmement important sur les
populations les plus fragiles bien
entendu que nous avons pas hésité à
maintenir l'indexation de toute les
prestations de tous les minimas sociaux
pour protéger ceux qui en avaient le
plus besoin et pour faire face au risque
d'explosion de la précarité qui est lié
à l'inflation l'inflation je le redis
c'est un drame pour les ménages les plus
modestes pour ceux qui ont moins
d'opportunités pour ceux qui n'ont pas
d'emploi et les moyens de faire face
sont extrêmement limités c'est là que la
solidarité nationale doit jouer à plein
je pense que nous avons fait ce qui
était nécessaire sur les salaires moi je
constate qu'il y a une augmentation en
moyenne de 4 3 % au dernier trimestre
2023 donc les entreprises continuent
d'augmenter en moyenne les salaires
ensuite là nous divergerons c'est que il
y a deux options pour que continue
d'augmenter je pense que je je partage
totalementot préoccupation qui est
d'augmenter les salaires et de faire en
sorte que le travail paye davantage mais
on peut le décréter par la loi je
comprends que c'est ce que vous proposez
avec un SMIC qui sera fixé par la loi là
c'est pas compliqué nous aurons une
explosion du chômage ce n'est pas ce que
je souhaite parce que ce n'est pas le
législateur qui décide du montant auquel
doit être payé un salarié sinon vous il
y a un salaire minimum oui mais ce n'est
pas nous qui décidons du montant des
salaires ce sont les entreprises et je
pense que si nous changeons de politique
nous risquons fort d'avoir une explosion
du chômage la deuxème chose c'est que la
meilleure façon d'avoir des salaires
plus élevés c'est la réindustrialisation
et c'est la productivité si vous
améliorez l'industrialisation et la
productivité du pays vous créez plus de
valeur donc il y a plus de prospérité et
des salaires qui sont plus élevés enfin
la troisème question qu'il faut se poser
c'est évidemment celle des charges
sociales c'est une question beaucoup
plus structurelle mais dans le fond
cotisation j'étais on était déçu de ne
pas entendre cette remarque donc
cotisation c'est pour ça d'où mon
sourire je suis satisfait d'entendre
donc je me corrige tout de suite pour
bien montrer à Fabien Guay que je ne
suis pas à droit dans mes bottes etid
comme un coup de tric cotisation et pas
charge il est évident que lorsque le
salarié regarde son bulletin de paye et
qu'il voit la somme des lignes et ce
qu'on lui retire par rapport à son
salaire brut il se demande est-ce que
j'en ai pour mon argent c'est une des
grandes question du modèle social
français on va pas la régler ici mais je
pense que c'est une des grandes
questions du modèle social
français merci de me rappeler à mes dev
voir Atos d'abord petit rappel atos est
une entreprise à 100 % privé parit de DF
tout à l'heure 100 % capitaux public à
entreprise à 100 % capitaux privé donc
ce n'est pas l'état qui gère Atos
ensuite Atos a deux types
d'activités on dit Atos on a le
sentiment os ne fait que des activités
ultra stratégiques non il y a une part
d'activité qui est stratégique qui est
dans la branche dite évident qui
comprend deux sous-branches le digital
avec le clot de confiance les systèmes
d'information et la branche qui est sans
doute la plus sensible qui est la
branche c'est super calculateur HPC dite
branche BDS et vous avez toute une autre
part d'activité qui elle n'a pas de
sensibilité particulière qui est
l'activité d'info gérant c'est-à-dire de
stockage de données non sensibles c'est
ce qu'on appelle tech
Foundation la direction d'Atos a fait le
choix de diviser son activité en deux
grandes parties tech Foundation est
évident c'est la
responsabilité du conseil
d'administration d'Atos ça n'est pas la
responsabilité de l'État moi ma seule
responsabilité et croyez-moi je
l'exercerai avec toute la fermeté
nécessaire c'est de m'assurer que les
activités stratégiques d'Atos restent
sous contrôle
français et j'ai les moyens de le faire
grâce au décret sur les investissements
étrangers en France pour m'assurer que
le capital d'Atos sur les activités
stratégiques restent sous contrôle
exclusif de la
France Merci alors on va passer Yannick
jade Henry Cabanel et Daniel Laurent
rapidement s'il vous plaît merci madame
la Présidente monsieur le ministre le
comité chargé d'évaluer les réformes de
la fiscalité du capital vous savez viend
de rendre son rapport il est sans appel
le passage de l' de l'ISF à l'IFI et le
prélèvement forfaitataire unitaire sur
le sur le capital nous coûte en 2022 4,5
milliards n'ont absolument aucun effet
sur l'investissement et les salaires et
au
contraire augmenter stress
significativement les dividendes et
l'accrossement des richesses des
trèshauts
patrimoines vous nous dites que vous
n'êtes pas raid comme un coup de tric il
y avait déjà la promesse du président de
la République était de dire s'il y a pas
d'effet sur l'investissement nous
reviendrons sur ces mesures est-ce que
vous êtes prêt à revenir sur ces mesures
qui nous permettraient d'avoir un peu
plus de souplesse sur les recettes et
puis par exemple en mettant en œuvre ce
qu'à proposé ce qu'on proposé Madame
mafou et Monsieur Pisani Ferri un impôt
exceptionnel pour financer la transition
écologique deuxième petite question mais
très courte une
phrase l'accord UE Mercosur votre
secrétaire d'État au Commerce dit un peu
près tout et son contraire sur l'accord
de la France sur UE Mercosur est-ce que
vous pouvez nous garantir que la France
va pas s'engager dans ce mauvais accord
au regard des conditions qu'il a
aujourd'hui merci Henri abanel merci
madame la Présidente Monsieur le le le
ministre la crise de l'immobilier avec
notamment le le le taux d'usure qui
empêche de nombreux ménages à passer à
l'acte d'achat affecte l'économie en
général avec un effet papillon sur tous
les corps de métiers liés à l'immobilier
et je ne parle pas donc de la chute des
droits de mutation qui impactent les
budgets des des départements vous avez
indiqué vouloir solvabiliser un grand
nombre de ménages pour leur permettre
d'acheter un bien et surtout de faire
construire quelles sont les solutions
pour faire redémarrer le marché dans vos
propos liminires vous avez expliqué je
suis d'accord avec vous que il n'y
aurait plus de subvention publique sur
les productiontion hors Europe vous
n'êtes pas sans savoir en ce qui
concerne les énergies renouvelables que
la Chine a un stock de panneaux solaires
important je crois que ça s'élève à 200
millions de panneaux solaires qu'il
souhait donc donc mettre sur le marché
et mettre en péril certainement des
entreprises françaises et européennes
doisje je comprendre que sur euh les
projets privés tous les projets qui
auront des panneaux solaires chinois ne
seront pas subventionnés et enfin
dernière question vous l'avez dit aussi
dans vos propos liminires vous êtes
légitime pour penser à une croissance de
1,4 % sur l'année 2024 alors que les
institutions économiques comme la Banque
de France prévoi 0,9 que l'Observatoire
des conjoncture économique prévoit 0,8
ben quels pourrait être les arguments
qui pourraient vous donner raison
merci Daniel Laurent oui
madame l'industrie dans le cadre de la
loi de finances pour 2024 l'article 28
du texte initial prévoit une nouvelle
réduction pérenne de 25 millions d'euros
dès 2024 avec d'autres réductions
envisagées pour les années à venir pour
mémoire la taxe affectée au CCI est
passée de
1350 millions d'euros en 2003 13 à 525
millions d'euros en 2023 deux
prélèvements exceptionnels sur fond de
roulement ont été opérés 170 millions
d'euros en 2014 et 500 millions d'euros
en 2015 quant aux effectifs ils sont
passés de 25000 en 2013 à 14000 en 2023
et malgré cela le président de la CCI de
Charente Maritime me disait encore tout
faire pour préserver leur mission de
proximité dans les bassins économiques
de nos territoires elles sont également
mobilisées vous le savez monsieur
sur nombreuses politiques publiques
prioritaires de l'État comme vous le
savez ces missions de service public
sont déficitaire alors qu'elles viennent
de signer un contrat d'objectif et de
performance avec l'État déterminant
l'exercice de leur mission pour les
quatre prochaines années à niveau de
ressources stables le réseau des CCI ne
pourra pas faire face à une nouvelle
diminution de sa ressources fiscales ces
préoccupations sont également partagées
par les chambres des métiers et de
l'artisan et les Chambres d'agriculture
monsieur le ministre merci de votre
réponse c'est à vous monsieur le
ministre pour répondre à ces trois
collègues alors Yannick
jado sur la fiscalité du capital j'ai
évidemment une vue un peu
différente moi j'estime et le rapport on
peut le lire dans le sens que l'on veut
que la mise en place du pfu qui je le
rappelle est dans la moyenne des pays
européens et reste supérieur à certain
de pays européens Allemagne comprise est
essentielle pour l'attractivité de notre
pays essentielle pour la création
d'entreprise et donc ces réformes
fiscales ont eu un impact très positif
sur l'attractivité du pays les
investissements donc qui viennent en
France et la création
d'entreprise donc à mes yeux la
stabilité étant une vraie vertu en
matière fiscale nous aurions tout
intérêt à maintenir ces dispositifs
fiscaux en l'état sur le Mercosur je
vous confirme la fermeté
du
gouvernement je pense qu'il sera un peu
paradoxal de défendre la production en
France et en Europe et dans le même
temps d'ouvrir la voie à la signature
d'accord de libre échange qui ne
garantirait pas le respect de ces
productions en France et en Europe donc
il n'y a pas d'inquiétude à avoir sur la
fermeté du Gouvernement en la
matière Henry Cabanel sur le marché du
logement je vais pas reprendre ce que
j'ai déjà indiqué je pense que c'est une
priorité absol
ça suppose de bouger un certain nombre
de curseurs qui ne sont pas simples à
faire bouger notamment d'assouplir un
certain nombre de règles dans le cadre
du ha Conseil de stabilité financière
j'en discute avec le gouverneur de la
Banque de France et avec les
personnalités qualifiées mais je le
redis il y a urgence à construire plus
vite de meilleurs logements partout où
la situation est tendue en France
ensuite sur ce que vous dites sur les
panneaux solaires j'ai peur queil faille
l'étendre au pompes à chaleur au moins
certaines partie des pompes à chaleur au
composants
d'éoliennes surtout depuis les
difficultés qu'à rencontré l'entreprise
Siemens et au véhicules électriques donc
moi je suis favorable à une mesure très
radicale qui consiste à accorder des
aides aux produits à contenu européen
alors je sais que ça se heurte à des
totem absolus de la construction
européenne mais les totems sont faits
parfois pour être renversés et je
considère que nous aurions tout intérêt
à nous battre dans les mois qui viennent
il va y avoir les élections européennes
pour que les aides soient réservées à
des produits industriels à contenu
européens c'est ce que font les
Américains c'est ce que font les Chinois
ça ne ferait que rétablir la balance
entre les trois grands continents
économique de la planète je vous dis pas
que ce soit gagné je pense que c'est
difficile mais je suis très favorable à
cette orientation là même si elle est
Yannick jado le disait tout à l'heure
compliquée du point point de vue
juridique compliqué du point de vue
politique compliqué du point de vue du
Parlement européen également il faut
juste mesurer que si on ne prend pas les
décisions commerciales
nécessaires nos propres industriels ne
pourront pas résister à la concurrence
de certains produits où il y aura du
dumping en terme de
prix enfin sur la croissance notre
chiffre est proche de celui avancé par
l'OCDE 1,2 points pour la France pour
2023 24 pardon et et le FMI qui nous met
à 1,3 pour 2024 donc nous avons d'autres
éléments positifs qui sont annoncés par
les instituts de conjoncture enfin
Daniel Laurent sur les CCI j'ai accepté
que nous revoyons notre copie sur les
budgets de la CCI des
CCI donc les les CCI n'ont pas
d'inquiétude particulière à avoir je
rappelle juste que nous avons réussi à
engager une réforme structurelle des CCI
qui a ramené le budget des CCI de 1,3
milliards à 525 millions d'euros j'ai
pas le sentiment que ça a affecté la
croissance économique de notre
pays j'ai pas le sentiment que ça ait
affecté la création d'emploi dans notre
pays peut-être mais c'est quasiment 1
milliard d'euros d'économie toute
économie est difficile il y a pas
d'économie facile toute économie est
difficile mais quand je regarde les
économies que nous avons réussi à faire
et je salue d'ailleurs l'engagement des
CCI qui se sont engagés de manière très
volontariste dans cette voie-là le
milliard d'euros d'économie que nous
avons fait et les résultats économiques
je pense que nous avons fait avec les
CCI en accord avec elle œuvre utile
maintenant une fois encore je constate
que la charge semblait trop lourde et la
marge trop haute pour l'année 2024 nous
avons donc révisé notre copie alors nous
passons à Bernard buit Jean-Claude
tissau et Rémi Cardon merci présidente
rapidement deux questions monsieur le
ministre au 31 décembre 2023 le titre
restaurant ne permettra plus d'acheter
des denrées non non périssable comme
c'est le cas actuellement que
comptez-vous faire une prolongation de
cette utilisation est-elle envisageable
ma deuxième question porte sur les
conditions actuelles d'emprunt
immobilier dans un contexte où la hausse
des taux d'intérêt pèse sur le marché
immobilier pensez-vous que les
conditions d'emprunt immobilier vont
évoluer dans les semaines à venir
oui merci madame la Présidente Monsieur
le Ministre moi je souhaiterais vous
interpeller sur le remboursement demandé
à certaines communes au titre du filet
de sécurité sur l'ensemble du territoire
national 3425 collectivités vont devoir
rembourser tout toutou parti de la
compte qu'elles avaient reçu pour un
montant total de 69,8 millions d'euros
dans mon département la Loire 39
communes sont concerné cette disposition
apparaît comme particulièrement injuste
pour les élus locaux notamment car ces
derniers ne disposaient pas ne
disposaient pas de l'ensemble des
indicateurs financier lors du versement
de cette somme et d'autre part car
l'évaluation de la santé financière des
communes semble abusive au regard de la
réalité du terrain alors que les
communes doivent déjà faire face un
contexte budgétaire difficile que soit
dû à la hausse des prix de l'énergie et
la baisse continue de dotation ces
demandes de remboursement risquent de
durablement fragiliser les finances des
collectivités concernées monsieur le
ministre est-ce que vous comptez
entendre les inquiétudes des élus locaux
sur ce sujet en commençant par suspendre
ces demandes de remboursement une
deuxième question rapide madame la
Présidente euh portera sur l'économie
sociale et solidaire qui joue un rôle
primordial en manière en matière de
transition sociale et écologique et qui
a su être résiliente face aux crises de
ces dernières années pourtant les
soutiens à l'économie sociale et
solidaire qui figurent dans ce projet de
loi finances sont particulièrement
faibles et si on les compare au crédit
accordés aux entreprises classiques
plusieurs organes ovrant pour le SS
mériteraient pourtant d'être renforcés
je pense notamment au Dispositif Local
d'Accompagnement et au ou aux Chambres
régionales de l'économie sociale et
solidaire et cela passe indéiablement
par des moyens supplémentaires pour
engager une nouvelle dynamique pour
cette filière alors que l'Espagne vient
débloquer un plan d'investissement en
faveur de le SS de 800 millions d'euros
comptez-vous monsieur le ministre
renforcer les moyens accordés à ce au
sein de ce PLF et juste une phrase vous
me permettrez monsieur le ministre comme
vous avez abordé l'agriculture tout à
l'heure je me permets juste de de vous
d'attirer votre attention je poserai la
question tout à l'heure à Monsieur feno
sur la les dégâts de la tempête que euh
que vient de subir l'ouest de notre pays
avec une difficulté qu'on va rencontrer
les éleveurs ouou essentiellement aussi
les maréchés euh sur la les les les les
les problématiques de production qui
vont devoir assurer aujourd'hui mais euh
permettez-moi d'insister sur les minimis
de quelle manière on pourrait faire
sauter entre guillemets ces minimis pour
justement pouvoir accompagner
efficacement les producteurs merci
rapidement remémy
Cardon monsieur le ministre il y a eu
effectivement un projet de loi sur la
protection du pouvoir d'achat voilà que
le 1er janvier 2024 les titres
restaurant ne permettront plus d'acheter
des produits de base comme le riz les
pâtes les œufs et cetera mais seulement
des plats cuisinés transformés et
transformer c'est souvent des plats
industriels qu'est-ce que vous allez
dire monsieur le ministre aux 5 millions
de bénéficiaires des titres resto qui
font chaque jour parfois leur cour du
fait que il y a ils ont des difficultés
au vu des des pertes de salair lié à
l'inflation donc ça c'est la première
question donc est-ce que vous allez
revoir ce resserrage autour des titres
restaurant et puis la deè question c'est
avez-vous des nouvelles de la promesse
du président de la République sur le
chèque alimentaire durable
voilà merci monsieur le ministre c'est à
vous
comme vous le savez je ne suis pas pour
la multiplication des checs donc toute
autre possibilité je ne pense pas bonne
politique sociale de multiplier l'échec
la meilleure politique c'est celle qui
crée des emplois et des emplois bien
rémunéré mais je voudrais vous répondre
sur la question très importante du
ticket restaurant question qui m'a été
également posée par
Bernard ticket restaurant il concerne
parfaitement rappel 5
de
salariés il avait été prévu dans le
cadre de la loi pouvoir d'achat à l'été
2022 d'étendre la possibilité d'utiliser
ces titres restaurant pour acheter des
produits
alimentaires je rappelle que c'est un
amendement
parlementaire qui a ouvert cette
possibilité là c'est très précisément
l'amendement de madame la sénatrice
puissa qui était adopté dans le cadre de
la loi pouvoir d'achat de l'été 2022 ce
même amendement prévoyait que cette
possibilité d'utiliser le titre
restaurant pour acheter des produits
alimentaires s'arrête au 31 décembre
2023 qu'est-ce que je constate c'est que
si l'inflation baisse fortement et si
nous sommes je le redis sortie de la
crise inflationniste néanmoins
l'augmentation des prix alimentaires
reste très pénalisante pour des millions
de nos compatriotes donc je suis
favorable à ce que nous prolongions
au-delà du 31 décembre 2023 cette
disposition permettant d'utiliser
l'éticket restaurant pour acheter des
produits alimentaires est-ce que c'est
simple à faire non car il faut une
disposition législative donc nous sommes
en train d'étudier les possibilités
législatives qui permettrai d'étendre
au-delà du 31 décembre 2023 cette
faculté d'utilisation des tickets
restaurants au moment où je vous parle
je n'ai pas la solution législative je
vous dis très simplement mais je suis
favorable à cette extension donc tout ça
répond évidemment aussi à la question de
de Bernard buis c'est un sujet qui est
évidemment extrêmement important pour
des millions de nos compatriotes
Jean-Claude tissau sur les reprises d'
compte nous avons pris toutes les
mesures pour étaler cette
charge aucune collectivité ne sera mis
en difficulté du fait de la reprise d'
compte la réalité c'est que nous avions
sans doute prévu des accontes trop
généreux ce qui fait que un nombre de
collectivités se sont retrouvé avec une
situation financière plus favorable que
prévu nous sommes dans 75 % des cas sur
des montants inférieur à 10000 € pour 60
% inférieur à 5000 €. ça peut néanmoins
mettre des très petites communes en
difficulté je le redis nous ferons du
traitement au cas par cas aucune commune
ne sera pénalisée par cette reprise d'AC
compte quant au déminimis c'est un sujet
extrêmement sensible moi je suis
évidemment toujours favorable à ce que
on fasse évoluer les règles européennes
quand il y a une catastrophe comme
celle-là euh je rappelle juste qu'il
vaut mieux respecter les règles
européennes en la matière j'ai le
souvenir cuisant comme ministre de
l'Agriculture euh des fameux plans de
campagneù nous avions été obligés
d'aller récupérer plusieurs centaines de
millions d'euros euh chez des
agriculteurs à qui on avait promis la
lune la lune n'arrive pas tous les
matins euh et du coup il avait fallu
récupérer l'argent ensuite donc je
préfère qu'on prenne des dispositions
qui soient rigoureuses du point de vue
du droit communautaire pour qu'on nit
pas à récupérer l'argent ensuite auprès
des
agriculteurs merci on passe à Daniel
grémier Vivian Artigalas et Marianne
Margaté
oui merci madame la Présidente Monsieur
le Ministre euh vous l'avez évoqué la
relance industrielle est nécessaire dans
notre pays qui dit relance industrielle
dit besoins énergétiques qui dit besoins
énergétiques dit aussi des coûts
abordables pour notre économie
euh la commission des affaires
économiques en juillet 2022 avait
d'ailleurs sur le plan de relance
nucléaire euh dit et affirmer la
nécessité d'avoir un plan de financement
très clairroyant je reviendrai pas sur
la reen vous avez répondu je me
limiterai même si sur la reen les 70 €
monsieur le ministre c'est une
augmentation de 65 % par rapport au 42
et c'est une augmentation euh de 41 %
par par rapport au 493 qui avait à
l'époque voté le Sénat je le dis quand
même parce que c'est 41 % d'augmentation
65 % d'augmentation euh par contre sur
le fin financement du nouveau nucléaire
quelles sont vos propositions
aujourd'hui il y a beaucoup de débats il
y a un débat sur les contrats à long
terme il y a des garantie d'emprunt il y
a des l'idée d'avance remboursable il y
a aussi la mobilisation du livra
qu'est-ce que vous en tant que ministre
de l'économie et des finances de notre
pays préconisé et question aussi
importante nous allons examiner au
Parlement début de l'année la loi de
programmation sur la régulation
énergétique est-ce que le financement de
ce nouveau nucléaire en fera
partie merci madame la Présidente
Monsieur le Ministre 2024 c'est la fin
des crédits associés au plan avenir
montagne dont l'objectif était de
permettre la mise en œuvre de stratégies
touristique diversifié et durable on
nous renvoie maintenant vers le fond
vert encore une fois c'est le flou sur
une politique d'adaptation indispensable
pour de nombreux territoires or la
couverture géographique du plan avenir
montagne n'a permis d'accompagner qu'une
petite partie des territoires les
actions issues des stratégies ébauché
doivent monter maintenant en puissance
et être supporté financièrement et de
plus l'aide financière et en ingénierie
de la banque des territoires doit être
accompagné monsieur le ministre quelle
proposition avez-nous à vous faire pour
ces territoires dont les besoins restent
nombreux je vous remercie Marianne
Margaté merci madame la Présidente
Monsieur le Ministre le PLF prévoit une
réforme d'ensemble des redevances
perçues par les agences de l'eau ce qui
en soit est une bonne chose puisqu'il
s'agit d'augmentation de ces des moyens
de ces agences de 475 millions d'euros
par an toutefois cette augmentation des
moyens des agences ne passera pas par
une augmentation de la contribution
budgétaire de l'État mais par une
augmentation de la redevance sur la
consommation d'eau potable qui sera d
par tous nos concitoyens cette mesure se
traduira-t-elle par une augmentation de
la facture renchérissant toujours
toujours plus le prix du mètre cube
d'eau nécessaire au premiers besoins qui
à nos yeux devrait être eux gratuit par
contre je réagis très rapidement sur le
filet anti-inflation qui a été évoqué
par par mes collègues je pense qu'il est
très dommage que l'État ne revoit pas sa
position les communes sont déjà en
difficulté je suis sénatrice de samarne
85 % des communes ont une reprise d'
compte dans le département de Samar pour
plus de 2 millions d'euros même si ce
sont des petites sommes ce sont aussi
des petites communes qui se bagarre tous
les jours face à la hausse de la facture
d'énergie la hausse des denrées
alimentaires pour pour euh faire face à
l'augmentation du point d'indice donc
c'est une mesure brutale injuste et je
pense que B c'est à l'image des
dernières mesures du gouvernement à
l'égard des communes et donc une marque
de mépris qui est à mon avis regrettable
là Monsieur le Ministre non il y a aucun
mépris des communes je suis désolé je
peux pas laisser dire ça alors que nous
avons maintenu les dotations que nous
avons compensé par les ressources
dynamiques les recettes qui avaient été
supprimé notamment la TVA pour compenser
la suppression de la taxe d'habitation
il y a absolument aucun méprisis des
communes mais il y a une politique
financière qui est effectivement
rigoureuse qu'est-ce que je serai comme
ministre des Finances si lorsqu'il y a
de l'argent qui a été donné en trop
perçu je ne récupérai
PASF on le fait pour les ménages on le
fait pour les communes c'est c'est ma
responsabilité de ministre des Finances
c'est pas forcément très agréable mais
c'est un principe aussi de justice et
d'équité vis-à-vis de l'ensemble des
contribuables sur
le plan haut je partage l'avis en
revanche que vous avez donné et je pense
que les mesures que nous avons annoncé
doivent permettre et elles peuvent être
complétées de répondre à vos inquiétudes
euh Vivian artigala sur le plan avenir
Montag notre objectif est bien
d'inscrire dans la durée ce plan sinon
il aurait absolument aucune efficacité
donc moi je suis ouvert à toutes les
propositions pourrait me faire dans ce
domaine je rappelle que j'ai dans ma vie
politique toujours soutenu les communes
de montagne quelles ont bénéficier de
dispositif très spécifique pour la crise
du covid je pense qu'elle le mérite
parce qu'elles sont confronté à des
difficultés très particulières donc
faites-moi vos propositions sur ce sujet
Daniel gremiller je voudrais vraiment
qu'on ne fasse pas de comparaison qui
euh crée de la confusion on ne peut pas
dire que les 70 € le mgaw qui sont le
prix de référence que nous avons fixé
ave EDF c'est 65 % de plus que les 42 €
le mgawh c'est juste mathématiquement
mais c'est faux
économiquement parce que les 42 €
portent sur 110 taw alors que les 70 €
pent sur l'intégralité de la production
électrique nucléaire de DF donc faisons
vraiment attention je rappelle le choix
que nous avons fait on peut le critiquer
on peut le discuter c'est tout le mérite
et le charme de la démocratie mais sur
des bases qui sont justes je n'ai pas
voulu exposer les entreprises au marché
pour une part de la production
électrique ça leur donne une sécurité la
sécurité elle a un cooup il est le plus
bas possible mais elle a nécessairement
un cout mais il aurait été beaucoup plus
facile pour moi de dire voilà sur 70
terw on reconduit laaren laaren ça fait
que des perdant
EDF est perdant et les entreprises qui
ont une part d'arènees sont exposé pour
le reste du marché à une flambée des
prix électrique comme ceux que nous
avons connu au cours des deux années
passées donc je pense que ça n'était pas
la bonne solution
sur le financement du nucléaire bah
l'objectif justement c'est que DF puisse
porter une partie du coût de financement
de ces nouveaux réacteur nucléaire la
décision sera prise en 2024 les
parlementaires seront évidemment
associés à ces discussions je pense
qu'on aura de longues discussion sur le
sujet notre objectif est évidemment de
minimiser le coût pour les contribuables
et de minimiser le coût du capital c'est
les deux critères que nous retiendrons
pour le financement de ces nouveaux
réacteurs nucléaires alors si nos
collègues sont Conil reste CIN questions
Sophie primat Guillin Cambier Antoinette
Gul Éveline Renaud garabédian et
Christian Redon sarazie Sophie primat
merci madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Ministre merci de vos explications je
partage pas du tout votre vision sur la
fiscalité des collectivités
territoriales mais le débat serait
beaucoup trop long y compris sur la CVAE
je crois que c'est une erreur de couper
le lien entre la fiscalité et le
territoire ma question porte sur la
réunion interministérielle de Séville
sur l'espace puisque maintenant c'est
votre votre
responsabilité à titre
principal l'accès à l'espace c'est un
élément de souveraineté très important à
la fois pour la défense pour
l'observation de la Terre pour la
gestion des des données il n'y a pas
donc de de de sujet là-dessus je
regrette juste que aucun ministre
n'était présent à Séville pour marquer
l'intérêt de du gouvernement français
aux questions d'espace un accord a été
trouvé qui assure une nouvelle tranche
de financement bienvenue pour Arian et
pour nos industriels on dit d'ailleurs
que c'est un accord favorable aux
industriels néanmoins il y a des
questionnements plus généraux et des
inquiétudes plus générales d'abord un
questionnement sur l'ouverture à la
concurrence obtenue par les Allemands
notamment sur les petits lanceurs à
l'heure où Arian espace lance Maya la
question de l'avenir du du de courou euh
notamment euh puisque à la fois le plan
de tir de soyou d'AVIA d'Arian 5 sont
questionnés quelle est l'équilibre
aujourd'hui qui va être retenu pour euh
pour courou et puis plus généralement
des questions de relations avec nos
partenaires est-ce que il y a encore une
politique européenne de l'espace quand
nous avons des intérêts très divergents
avec nos amis allemands avec nos amis
italiens et avec les autres pays mais
qui sont moins contributeurs alors
j'avais oublié c'est une erur de ma part
Laurent Duplomb euh et puis ensuite
guidin
Cambier excusez-moi madame la Présidente
Monsieur le Ministre un temps j'ai cru
que vous étiez redevenu ministre de
l'agriculture en début du mois d'octobre
avec toutes les annonces que vous avez
faites et votre déplacement au Sommet de
l'élevage merci pour les 150 € les
agriculteurs l'apprécieront concernant
les évolutions euh du capital du cheptel
lié à l'augmentation des prix euh vous
avez modifié de façon importante la
tarification du GNR en supprimant une
partie de l'exonération sur les 7
prochaines années je suis ravi du fait
malgré tout que vous ayez pris les trois
grandes idées de la PPL que nous avions
voté au Sénat concernant les
exonérations des plus-values le
relèvement des seuils du microba et
laadp il n'en reste pas moins vrai que
j'ai trois petites questions la première
c'est que vous aviez annoncé dans un
premier temps que la compensation des
2,85 centimes d'euros d'exonération du G
représentait 70 millions de compensation
et puis quelques temps après ces 70
millions se sont transformés par 90
millions donc le jeu de bon tau des 20
millions j'aimerais bien que vous
puissiez m'apporter une petite précision
parce que personnellement je ne la
trouve pas le deuxième élément c'est que
je voudrais avoir de vos services ou de
vous-même si vous avez la réponse
l'évolution attendue de la consommation
du GNR lié à l'augmentation des prix vos
économ à mon avis ont déjà des
éclairages là-dessus en sachant qu'à mon
avis la consommation du GNR va pas
obligatoirement baisser puisque avec les
mesur de planification écologique on va
demander aux agriculteurs d' plus d'emer
plus souvent pour faire de la biomasse
ce qui par définition demandera un
travail du sol plus important et enfin
vous avez annoncé un crédit d'impôt
transition écologique à partir de 2025
pour avoir un troè volet de compensation
par rapport aux exonérations qui ont été
supprimé il semblerait que vous vous
ayez le principe de passer du B7 au B au
B30 pour le gasoil agricole voir sur le
baissant quels sont les contours du
crédit d'impôt que vous envisagez de
faire à partir 2025 de façon à ce que
les agriculteurs sachent à quel SAU ils
vont être mangés Guilain Cambier je suis
désolé après on s'arrêtera après Guilin
parce que monsieur le ministre doit
partir merci madame la présidente
monsieur le ministre vous avez fait un
pldoyer tout à l'heure à raison
d'ailleurs pour l'industrie verte pour
les gig et c'est vrai que dans dans les
Haut- de France dans le Nord on a tout
un écosystème qui qui se met en place il
est vrai cet écosystème il a besoin il a
besoin d'espace et lorsque lorsqu'on
regarde justement ce ce pladoyer pour
l'industrie verte je voulais faire le
lien avec le zan le zéro
artificialisation net pour lequel il y a
eu un un consensus parlementaire pour
autant on a des besoins d'implantation
qui dépassent largement l'offre en
friche en en terrain identifié ma
question est est donc euh enfin m deux
questions pour être précis euh à quant
les orientations du gouvernement sur la
liste exacte des entreprises
industrielles que vous avez retenu et de
leur consommation foncière c'est la
première question et de façon à manière
ENF de manière à à réussir cet
atterrissage territorial de façon à
faire de l'aménagement du territoire
concerté avez-vous une réflexion ou une
une orientation sur le le partage
justement de la de la taxe d'aménagement
entre commune et intercommunalité pour
que on puisse réussir ces implantations
localement merci monsieur le ministre
monsieur le ministre je pas la réponse à
toute dernière question d'Olivier de
guinin pardon Cambier sur les anes mon
objectif est d'avoir une vision large de
l'industrie verte si nous voulons
implanter les nouvelles entreprises
industrielles vertes nous avons besoin
de foncier et le premier obstacle au
développement de l'industrie en France
désormais ce sera le foncier donc il est
indispensable d'avoir du foncier du
foncier disponible d'avoir du foncier
clé en main c'est 56es clé en main si
nous voulons demain développer de
l'industrie on peut très bien ne pas
vouloir développer l'industrie et donc
être très strict sur le foncier c'est
tout à fait cohérent on peut vouloir
développer l'industrie et donner accès
au foncier mais développer l'industrie
sans foncier ça je ne sais pas faire ça
me fait furieusement penser à
l'industrie sans usine des années 90 on
a vu ce que ça avait donné Laurent duup
plomb je me félicite parce que ça arrive
rarement que nous soyons d'accord c'est
vrai donc je tiens à
saluer comme quoi tout arrive euh donc
sur le GNR je vous confirme
effectivement que nous sommes sur 2,85
centimes d'euros nous notre évaluation
reste à 70 millions d'euros et pas 90 je
vous confirme que l'intégralité des
recettes iront à la transition
écologique des agriculteurs et seront
accompagnés des mesures fiscales que
vous avez porté là aussi je rends à
César ce qui appartient à César
notamment les exonérations sur les
plusvalues et le BEP qui sont deux
propositions que vous aviez faites au
Sénat il y a quelques mois enfin sur le
B7 le B30 tout ça sera décidé d'ici fin
2024 aucune décision n encore été
arrêtée mais vos propositions sont les
bienvenues et je serai ravi de les
reprendre comme les précédentes Sophie
prima sur
l'espace je je termine par ce sujet qui
est évidemment un sujet totalement
stratégique notre objectif était de
garantir l'accès indépendant de l'Europe
à l'espace nous avons mené 3 mois de
négociations intenses avec les Allemands
les Italiens je me suis rendu à Berlin
je me suis rendu à Rome et nous avons eu
des discussions trilatéral entre
allemand français et italien intense
depuis 3 mois si je me suis pas rendu à
Séville c'est pour des raisons
impératives d'agenda je pense nous avons
trouvé un bon accord qui sécurise
l'accès indépendant de l'Europe à
l'espace mais qui nous fait rentrer
effectivement dans une nouvelle ère des
lanceurs spatiaux européens l'ancienne
ère c'est une dans lesquel l'argent
public est infiniment disponible et où
on se dit que la rentabilité du lanceur
n'a aucune espèce d'importance ça va
très bien tant vous avez pas spéx et
Falcon 9 le jour où vous avez SpaceX et
Falcon 9 ça va plus je pardon d'être
assez basique mais j'ai peur que la vie
soit assez basique en la matière donc
nous avons effectivement accepté et même
promu c'est pas les Allemands qui
étaient les seuls à défendre l'idée
d'une compétition sur les lanceurs nous
aussi nous avons porté la compétition
sur les lanceurs nous avons créé le
programme Maya pour un futur petit
lanceur réutilisable à la demande du
Président de la République il y a
maintenant 16 mois c'est effectivement
une révolution dans le domaine des
lanceurs nous rentrons dans la
compétition et plus simplement dans la
coordination à n'importe quel prix donc
que le meilleur gagne il y aura un appel
d'offre ce qu'on appelle un challenge
esa qui sera lancé en 2025 ils
regarderont où en sont les Allemands où
en sont les français où en sont les
Italiens et ils financeront à hauteur de
150 millions d'euros le programme qui
sera le plus avancé que le meilleur
gagne je souhaite évidemment que le
meilleur ce soit un lanceur français
mais nous rentrons effectivement dans
une logique très différente qui permet
de garantir la compétitivité des
lanceurs européens ça c'est le premier
point de l'accord c'est pas simplement
la demande des Allemands c'est aussi la
demande des Français qui voulent sortir
d'une logique institutionnelle trop
coûteuse 2 c'est le point le plus dur
nous garantissons l'avenir d'Aran 6
parce qu'avant de disposer d'un futur
gros lanceur ça prendra au moins 10 ans
il faut qu'arian 6 puisse être sécurisé
pour les 10 ans qui viennent avec des
financements à hauteur de 340 millions
d'euros par an nous avons sécurisé le
financement et obtenu des réductions de
tarifs de la part des PME sous-traitante
c'est le deième point de l'accord enfin
troème point de l'accord vous l'avez
parfaitement cité c'est l'utilisation du
site de courou nous avons obtenu de
récupérer le pas de tir de soyou qui
pour des raisons qui n'échappe à
personne ne peut plus être utilisé par
Soyuz et par la Russie nous allons
récupérer le pas de tir de Soyuz pour
Maya ce qui donne un avantage compétitif
important à la France et bien merci
beaucoup monsieur le le ministre pour
toutes ces réponses aux nombreuses
questions on a bien compris aussi que
vous étiez dans l'attente des
propositions que pourrait nous formuler
l'ensemble des commissaires sur les
questions qu'ils vous ont posé on vous
remercie on espère vous voir le plus
souvent possible dans l'hémicycle dès la
semaine prochaine à l'occasion de
l'ouverture des débats du PLF pour le
budget 2024 merci beaucoup
merci
sans plus tarder